ừ ừ
à à
anh
alo chả bạn
không nhận thỉnh thoảng mình thay đổi
thời gian một tí các bạn được thì không
biết được không biết được nên vào lúc
nào đúng ạ
Ừ cậu cứ phải 7 rưỡi ngồi canh không ạ
ở nhà máy xông mặt thời gian các bạn chỉ
cần 8 giờ là vào được là được rồi lúc
đấy giờ luôn Chuẩn rồi và sớm thì mày
nghe tâm sự một tí thôi không ạ
À hôm nay mình định tâm sự về cái vụ mà
Windows 11 từ có mấy lần các bạn nó hỏi
mình tại sao anh chưa lên Windows 10 à
Ẩm Thực ra là
mình đã cũng có nói đó là kiểu Ngụy
Windows 11 cho mình đang xem thì có vẻ
là nó vẫn chưa
nó vẫn chưa có gì đáng để lên ngoài cái
giao diện thay đổi bởi vì các chức năng
các thứ vẫn còn đang còn nhiều vấn đề
trục trặc
ông ngoại tự nhiên máy mình có máy làm
việc nữa tự nhiên lên Xong rồi có gì đó
tự nhiên mình phải gỡ đi hoặc cả phần
mềm gì đó mình bị lỗi lại mệt không ạ
à mà đúng nhưng mà hôm nay mình có bấm
vào xem cái con update bởi vì à Tự nhiên
là mình cũng muốn xem mà hiểu
máy điện thì update mà Thì mình đang
muốn mình thường hay về dân công nghệ
mình vẫn có tí tò mò kiểu là Nắp này nó
sẽ có cái gì mới thì mình cũng bấm vào
xem thử xem là cái phần Windows 11 thì
nó báo là máy của bạn không hỗ trợ để mà
lên Windows 11
nghĩa là không đặt cấu hình tối thiểu
luôn cho mình vào mình phải cài phần mềm
để vào xem xem lại cấu hình tối thiểu là
gì mà ghê gớm thế bởi cái máy minh thì
các bạn Máy mình mua không biết các bạn
biết chưa là mày đi mua là mày chạm vào
dòng hơi cũ một tí nhưng mà mày chạm là
hồi nãy mình mua trả góp là 38 triệu vì
mình nghĩ à rồi đấy Mình kiếm được tiền
cảm nhận hội giàu cái Sao kiểu Ý Anh
nghĩ rằng nằm ôm con mày chạm thô trong
vòng 6 đến 7 năm thoải mái mà cái quan
trọng mà đồ công nghệ Tiền Nào Của Nấy
theo kiểu là mình nghĩ thế nó giờ mình
nghĩ đó mà dùng 675 mà sướng sướng trong
lòng 6,5 đấy còn hơn là mệt yêu vợ thật
mua 235 dùng chán rồi lại phải đổi hai
ba năm rồi đó ngoài nó khác con điện
thoại ra mình cố Cô thích mua trả góp
cái con để tôi không thì mua Phải cái
con à Chắc là có mấy giúp như vậy
Mình đã từng bóc phốt phải bốn bày ở
trên YouTube có một tí rồi nên là mình
sẽ không nhắc lại thêm lần nữa đây thì
ra và mình thấy da mình cũng gỡ bà ấy
rồi họ có liên hệ với mình Họ họ bảo hỗ
trợ sửa mình có vấn đề gì đấy là máy giờ
thì vẫn chạy à A gọi là máy vẫn chạy
được không còn bị lỗi gì nữa nhưng mà nó
không hề trải nghiệm đúng của một con
mấy trạm
Nói chung là đại khái là máy mình mình
mình có vào xem cái cấu hình tối thiểu
đi thì người ta thì Máy mình bị thiếu
hai cái cả về CPU và cả với chip
sao còn nó bảo là
trong cái bài đang để nó còn nhắc cái từ
mà mình cảm thế Buồn vãi là thể cậu là
nữ ca sĩ CPU để mà đạt tiêu chuẩn
à À cái bảo mật đấy thì là CPU
CPU Chỉ cần
sau 2016 là đã có cái đều đều có về hỗ
trợ bảo mật đấy rồi nên các bạn không
cần phải lo
nghe có lấy Buồn vãi em chỉ em với con
CPU của mình còn cũ hơn nửa hay như 16
không hỗ trợ luôn ở đấy
các bạn đừng lo Ok Mọi khi thì mình chê
mà cái thằng bạn của mình kiểu chơi nó
lôi nó có lát mày nó có đều chưa máy nó
có lên được win 10 quên Win 11 Còn máy
mình thì không đủ tiêu chuẩn
ừ ừ
Ừ lúc nào kiểu mình nói thế là một cái
vừa tâm sự vừa để nói qua việc là là các
bạn mà không nên mua con mày cũ chứ đừng
đừng sai lầm như mình hồi đấy Mình thích
đeo mà rồi đều mới chạm thì nghe về ổn
nhưng mà thực ra đều chính hãng Việt Nam
thì nó
mình hồi đấy mình sai thì không có máy
mới nhà mình cứ nghĩ là mua máy cũ như
thế này Cuối cùng thì có phải có thể
mình nhầm thôi có thể mình đen thôi chả
ngán với thằng bạn mình mua ở đây thì
đến bây giờ nó vẫn sẽ ổn nhưng không
biết thế nào xung À đây
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi
main tp.tdm 2.0 đúng đúng rồi đấy Cái
của mình có 1.6 rồi à
đi sông ơi
con chích của mình cũng bị chẳng hiểu vì
sao bị hạ thấp vì vậy Chip xeon mà cũng
không hỗ trợ do người dòng chip đấy ạ
Ừ Ok mình xin phép nói nốt về cái vụ
Jack o
anh nói Nói nhanh hơn là nhanh luôn Ờ ờ
Ừ thì cậu không biết các bạn có điểm thế
nào về vụ Jack đến hình À thì ra Dân
mình thì sẽ tràn ra đa số vẫn còn đang
dùng crack win ít nhất là như thế bởi vì
kiểu mì ông bộ tiền ra đã bị sinh viên
nữa một tiền ra để mua win bản quyền khi
tốn kém quá không ạ mình không ý kiến
thì cái vụ crack các thứ như mình đang
nói việc cả thứ nhất là mấy ông phải béo
dân công nghệ thì mày ông thì nhất à
phải biết chị tìm những cái Trang mà có
Tùy uy tín thì các bạn tại về để mặc
crack cũng như là nói chung là dùng bản
là gọi là reset
khi reset bản thử nghiệm thì sẽ chào là
bản thử nghiệm
mấy hôm ấy ông có thể cho hàng thức này
để mà gần như là mày không được dùng thì
nếu không phải nên tải ở những trang Uy
tín một tí về tránh việc là dân công
nghệ không không biết mấy cái trang uy
tín thì tay tôi thấy mình cái trang
trang nào ở trên trang đầu của Google là
tải thì chết
Ừ
anh nhưng có rất nhiều cái có nhận âm
tracklist nó hơi khó Nhưng nói chung ở
tôi nói thế thì mấy ông cũng phải cũng
phải cân nhắc lại việc làm với ông ham
về việc crack nhiều quá trên mạng đưa
ông Võ Black Pearl cream Có nhưng mà
phải xem lại cái trang đời không ạ Không
không thì chuyện là máy ông bị virus thì
xong rồi Thậm chí đã bị bị mã hóa hết
toàn bộ file Rồi nó đòi tiền
Ừ thì lúc đấy thì dân công nghệ với đi
không ạ
mà cho nó rất hạn chế điều này có thể
xảy ra
bà nhưng mà tôi không khuyên mày ông hẳn
ở crack nhiều
bởi vì là crack crack thì mình là dân
cũng nghệ Mình là dân làm làm bán sản
phẩm bằng chất xám thì mình cũng phải
tôn trọng ra bởi vì sau nhớ đâu mình làm
ra các sản phẩm gì đó người ta cũng
crack của mình Vì sao đúng ạ mình phải
tôn trọng người ta khi Mình đi làm mình
có tiền rồi đấy thế này mình cũng mua
rất nhiều cái xanh qua các thứ cây cả
mình đã từng từng crack nó hay là mình
mình kiểu dùng nó miễn phí nữa Nhưng
mình dùng nó lâu rồi đấy Thì mình cũng
mua bản quyền cho nó giống như tôi từng
kể ông vụ vợ tôi mua cái bản bản quyền
của thằng sắp tay tách cả hãng bây giờ
tôi thấy không nhận nó khá đắt cho rồi
nó miễn phí nhưng mà tao vẫn mua ngoại
anh
nghe cảm nhận quả đấy tôi bấm nhầm đấy
Tôi cứ tưởng nó 8 đô màu trắng video nữa
tao mới Đô thì tôi sẽ xem xét lại đúng
không ạ
Ừ ok Bây giờ hết rồi Sang phần bên này
có hỏi đầu tiên gì à
à à đầu tiên về vụ ôtô xếp
à Hôm trước có chính sinh viên của mình
hôm trước cũng bị dính đó là Kiều ở
tôi khi là cậu quên
cài đặt lệch
[âm nhạc]
alo a
đề thi thì mình mình cạn mình thư da là
các bạn phải quen dần việc à Gõ cốt đến
đâu thì ăn cân cho net này để liên tục
nhận chị ấn vài lần nó chắc mình toàn
thế mình thêm một dấu cách 2 thấy tôm
nghĩnh khỏe internet này lần sợ lò kiểu
máy có vấn đề gì đấy tự nhiên tắt máy mở
lại mới thấy cốt của mình đã cốt
Còn nếu mà các bạn quên đi thì có có thể
cài những cái ví dụ lập retain kiểu ngay
canxi P là xong rồi Pocket này Ừ thôi
đây sẽ áp Pocket
a Pocket bình a Pocket jean Skinny
kaki sau đó chọn là autoset để nó sẽ tự
động lưu các bạn nằm dưới một lần
ngay
cái đấy phải sau đó tách còn những thằng
khác thì đôi khi nó tự động và các bạn
rồi
những thằng IDM thường này nó tự động
các bạn vụ đấy rồi
tiếp theo hôm trước có bạn nói về Quảng
cáo Facebook việc là em Em ở ẩn danh em
vẫn đô thị dưới nguồn cáo em vẫn thường
xuyên gặp quảng cáo thôi em có cha mày
cái này đâu Nó vẫn dính quảng cáo anh
Bảo ở Quảng cáo nó dựa trên Cookie Nhưng
rõ các em có truy cập máy xanh ở đâu vẫn
quảng cáo này Thực ra là nó nó sai em
sai rồi con điện là
Facebook chỉ dựa vào mỗi Cookie các bạn
để quảng cáo là sai của huyền thứ nhất
là quảng cáo là mũi có bơm của nó nên là
một khi là nó không lấy cái thông tin gì
của bạn ấy thì thực ra là nó sẽ đề xuất
cho các bạn những cái quảng cáo của cái
độ tuổi cũng như là giới tính cũng như
là vùng miền
Ừ nó rỡ heo tất cả những cái tiêu chí
đấy để mà kiểu gì phải quảng cáo cho một
cái gì đó nghĩa là nếu mà Mấy ông mà tầm
tuổi tầm tuổi Tôi ở nạn chờ thêm vài năm
nữa rồi kết hợp việc là nó biết mình sẽ
em giờ này đi cho nó quảng cáo về mấy
cái bệnh về xương khớp nữa chị
kiểu thế nếu nếu là nếu mà người ông
không cho nó biết được thêm cái gì về
ông thế nên là song ca tôi nhiều lúc tôi
muốn nó quảng cáo đúng bằng cách mà tôi
nó không không mở danh tôi sẽ tôi sẽ tra
tài liệu hay tìm kiếm cái gì đó mà còn
mà tôi quan tâm ở trên trên máy của tôi
để nó đọc kỹ rồi nó đi sắp có vẻ hợp lý
thí vậy ông không ở thể chặn được Nó
không có thể kêu là cài tiện ích trên
trình duyệt để chọn nó nhưng mà ông nước
bằng mạng lưới bằng điện thoại thì cũng
dính không ạ Nên là ông đừng có nghĩ về
cắt được cần câu cơm Nó ông chỉ hãy làm
con nó đề xuất ông thông minh hơn chị
thay vì kiểu hiển thị ra những cái nghị
cảm không ạ
ừ ừ
a tiếp theo về Cookie netflix có bạn hôm
trước bảo là thế chia sẻ có kinetec là
xạ để mà chưa cập vào tài khoản người
khác thì sao thì cái này thì ra là hồi
xưa mình từng nói về cái tiện ích nó
tương tự nó lá nó tiện ích ra
anh access your
extensions
có vẻ là cái này bị bay ở trên chrome
rồi đấy tôi dùng cái này ngon phết là nó
bản chất là nó
ơ cái thằng này nó khác với cái Cookie
một tí ạ Nó vẫn nó vẫn không có chữ
Cookie nhưng mà nó đẩy lên trang nó đẩy
lên cái server của nó
Ê bà tạo làm cái Linh sau đó mấy ông chỉ
cần gửi link này cho người khác thì mình
thì nó bảo mật hơn rồi điểm là người
khác không biết làm Mochi ở màu gì người
ta và người ta có linh những người đang
truy cập được
mà cái link này ông còn thể đặt theo
kiểu là giới hạn thời gian nữa Còn không
thì ông sẽ có kiểu là của anh Tuấn hay
dùng nó là giữ Tiên Cookie nó cậu xuất
ra cái file Cookie từ từ cái phiên đăng
nhập của ông từ 1 trang bất kỳ cho ông
ông bảo người khác cũng cài cái này để
mà inbox vào thì khi sẽ đăng nhập được
đó cái đấy có chê đây nó làm trên rất
nhiều
trên rất nhiều tài khoản không phải mỗi
netflix Nhưng mà nếu thích thì thì ra là
cái đấy nửa giờ nữa không một việc
netflix thì nó chơi chưa theo cả chế độ
nó Lan là giống thằng Zalo đấy Đó là nó
bắt chị xem là người dùng có đang truy
cập nhiều thiết bị cùng một lúc hay
không
Vì thế nên là mấy ông mà cùng xem cùng
một lúc thì mấy ông sẽ bị văng ra thôi
nó làm cái câu chờ đấy nữa cơ Chứ không
phải là mỗi kiểm tra quyền đăng nhập
a tiếp theo về dịch vụ mà có bạn Linh
Phương Linh hôm trước hỏi về các em phân
quyền có giới hạn quyền để áp dụng với
cái hôm trước bài hôm trước thì cho ra
cái này lên quan việc là mình có cuối
buổi mình còn nói qua một tí đó là các
bạn thiết kế đa ta bây sao cho
kiểu tách bảng ra bản quyền này lại nó
sẽ kiểu như ngay à
anh ở đây là sự đây bạn quyên này
tôi Mission đúng không ạ Nó sẽ là
ai đi nữa sau đó anh em đã này Đây là sẽ
edit này rồi nhưng shop chẳng hạn thế
anh như này thấy mình đang ví dụ anh nhá
các bạn sẽ có cho Ken To Ken bơm Asen là
số đó là bạn trung gian giữa permission
ô tô can Quyền đi quyền sử dụng tiếng
Anh đoạn này được nó sẽ là
ai đi Chó Ken đi anh đi cho kem và ed
Quyền nó bảo trung gian giữa thằng Token
với thằng này ai đi này sau đó thì đây
sẽ là mã và rudy
một này ABC này đây sẽ là một để ID
quyền không ạ một này một này hay cửa
nhà thì sẽ nghĩ hiểu là cái
khi cây tóc kia này nó sẽ có hai quyền
tướng như này thế thôi
ở đây cách thiết kế tương đối tương đối
của một cái data pay liên quan việc và
một tóc em có thể nhiều quyền ngoại
A và phun quyền để ám chỉ ở đơn giản là
thích hết tất cả những cái kia thôi
a tiếp theo có bạn nói về cái
mình có thể dùng md5 để mà mã hóa thứ
nhất là mấy bạn tranh cãi về vụ là dịch
được kể hát mái không Nếu mà thực ra các
bạn kết qua khái niệm en Cốt và đi cốt
em Cốt nó cũng là mã hóa Nếu mà dịch nếu
dịch kiếm việc là thế đi cốc thì nó giải
mã nghĩa là dịch ngược lại thì kệ hát
thì nó sẽ khác một tí hát là bom nó sẽ
ban ra và nó sẽ nó sẽ kiểu cũng có mã
hóa như nó kết hợp với một vài cái nữa
để mà khó mà giải mã gần như Rất Khó
Giải mã hẹn Thế thì cái vụ hmd5 Hiện tại
thì vẫn không dài được không có cái hàm
là lời dạy nó ra nhưng mà mình khuyên là
các bạn cũng không nên dùng hmd5 cái vụ
này hồi trước mình từng nói về cái á
nên bầu t bồ sẽ làm gì ạ Nếu mà em có
một cái Rainbow table cho cả một cái
bảng có có hàng tỷ trăm tỷ
những cái bản md5 đã được mã hóa
sau khi nấu thì dựng ngược da của bạn
Tại sao đây mình sẽ ví dụ các bạn một
cái ngoài 5 Online II ở đây mình sẽ thử
mã hóa để 123 này ẩn này các bạn thời ra
số này không ạ bên bị ấn lại lần nữa các
bạn thấy nó vẫn là số này bên mình tải
lại cha mình ấn lại phát nữa nó vẫn chỉ
ra số ngày thôi Bởi vì sao Bởi vì 10 năm
thì nó sẽ luôn mã hóa nó thành nó có một
cái hàm đấy để ra hình cái số này đúng
không ạ Ok đầu tiên thì cái chỗ này Các
bạn nhìn vào lúc đầu sẽ khó dạy Nhưng mà
nếu mà giờ xử Cái này có sẵn trong B các
bạn Thôi thì các bạn hoàn toàn thể dịch
ngược được nó lại thành 1 2 3 và các bạn
đã từng dịch nó lành từ 123 thành như
này rồi thì gọi chị sẽ ngược lại thôi
nghe cái bảng cái có 100 tỷ bảng thì nó
sẽ dịch lại được những cái mà đã đã từng
được mã hóa
Điền hình Bây giờ Bây giờ các bạn cha
mời năm đi cốt dict là thế mày đi cốt xe
tải thì nó xảy ra
Anh đang à à
ở đây nó sẽ quickset xét này
có phải nó sẽ ra 1 2 3
I dig Deep và giải mã nó dịch ra như thế
Ừ ok chưa Thế là các bạn không nên dùng
cái Hà nó mà kiểu cư cứ băn nó nó chỉ ra
được như thế thì hacker vẫn có thể dùng
Weibo thế Bồ để nó ra thế nên là các bạn
đã một là hồi trước mình đã từng nói là
kết hợp với San với paper để mà hiểu cái
đoạn đấy nó sẽ ra phức tạp hơn hoặc là
các bạn dùng cái mấy cái Hà nó liên quan
đến thời gian mà không liên quan gì đó
giống như thậm chí à
đối với đối với máy tính nó quấy cái từ
ngẫu nhiên nó ẩm thực ra không phải là
ngẫu nhiên cơ
cho mấy bạn nghĩ rằng ạ máy tính thì nó
sẽ mày cái random này là ngẫu nhiên đối
với người không ạ Chị ra con người mình
không nói làm cái gì ở ngẫu nhiên rồi
con người mình sẽ Nó những cái mà mình
đã có sẵn trong đầu để mình bật ra thế
nên là máy tính cũng thế cái khái niệm
ngẫu nhiên thực sự này IELTS này sự ngẫu
nhất thời sự không hề tồn tại thế nên là
thằng này cái hòm Thằng này nó phải chơi
cái thế nó
Ừ nó dùng cái thời tiết thì phải mình
nhớ là và sử dụng cái thời tiết để mà độ
ẩm cho người tuyết hai cái gì gió ấy
mình nhớ hồi đấy mình đọc ơi ở đây không
biết đấy à độ ồn độ ôn của
nghe tiếng ồn trong khí quyển này đấy
à à
ở
đài non nó mới ra được một cái hàm ngẫu
nhiên thì dưới đó để mà ra tới thằng cái
cái cái thằng này thì chơi cái đấy còn
các bạn có thể chơi bằng một cái gì bất
kỳ kết hợp tin thời gian hiện tại được
can tell me DJ thực ra ở rất khó ai đoán
được rồi được kết hợp với hàm hát nào đó
bất kỳ nữa là gần như sẽ không dịch được
Đấy vậy là một cách
Ừ thôi mình nói nốt cái này chứng anh
nhé Hôm nay thật ra bố không Mai dài đấy
à tiếp theo nên học à
Có nên học cái gì đó Nói chung không về
công nghệ thông tin công nghệ thông tin
mình được cái là cái gì nó có tí liên
quan đến nhau Nhưng mà thực sự thì cho
dù cái cắm con người mà đa-zi-năng một
tí như mình mình cũng không khuyên các
bạn là nên học dàn trải mà các bạn ấy
học tập trung hẳn một cái gì đó đã có
cái gì đó kiểu thật sâu đã
có một thứ để mà các bạn có thể xin được
việc đã sau đó đây các bạn
có thể từ đó các bạn sẽ định hướng dẫn
mình có thể phù hợp nhau gì là sự như
mình mình không phù hợp để mà học lý
thuyết nhiều quá thì mình sẽ học cái
khác còn nếu mà các bạn học được lý
thuyết khô khan mà các bạn cảm thấy nó
hay mày nó cuốn thì các bạn thể học thêm
ví dụ về thuật toán 2 computer sian khoa
học khoảng khoảng máy tính tại kiểu thế
Ok nhá giải đáp được khá nhiều nhé
Ừ hôm nay anh sẽ bàn về đồ án cuối giờ
nữa cơ hội Bộ hôm nay ra đấy em mấy ông
cố chịu khó cho kịp nhé
cho nó tiền gì hôm hôm nay mình sẽ dạy
các bạn về ạ giỏ hàng không ạ nghĩa là
sao Nó là kiểu đầu tiên thì các bạn nhớ
hôm trước vào thì sẽ
à
mình để nó di tru rồi
xe này Hôm trước cả vào xem toàn bộ sản
phẩm như thế này mình sẽ có nút là đặt
giờ sữa là mình nha mình bỏ qua vụ đăng
nhập là sự mình đăng nhập rồi đi đây
mình cần là bấm vào thì sẽ là thêm sản
phẩm cái SamSung này và giao hàng được
không ạ Đấy chúng mình thêm vào rồi mình
tăng số lượng của sản phẩm lên mình giảm
số lượng sản phẩm đi mình xóa giỏ hàng
hay ở gì đó Vân Vân Vân Xem giỏ hàng cái
số cũng được đặt hàng như nào thấy mình
là hôm nay mình kiểu mục tiêu mà như thế
không ạ
Ừ Ok chị bắt đi này à
Ừ tôi tại hình ảnh laptop ra như này mày
ông Chịu khó hơi bị đau mắt thì đi nhá
Nó tiền thì à Bây giờ mình cần có cái
nút ở đây để ấn vào đặt hàng không ạ
Mình sẽ là thủ đắt ở đây này xem chi
tiết ở đây
chị xem phim mấy ông có thể là vào Sang
chi tiết thì mấy ông mới mới có cái nút
đặt hàng cũng được hoặc là hàng ngay
ngoài lại được
à Đúng rồi tiền thế Đấy mình nói luôn
bởi vì ah Hôm trước mình bảo làm cái vụ
đăng nhập rồi bà chị khách hàng có tài
khoản mới có thể đặt thực Hà thì như nào
thì hôm nay mình sẽ chỉ các bạn luôn
cũng được đấy Đợi mình tí nhé đầu tiên
này Hôm trước mình đăng nhập chưa nhỉ à
ở đây để kiểm tra mình đăng nhập hay
chưa thì mình có thể xem luôn bên này
mình sẽ có ngay trên cung ở đây đi đây
Sistar ở đây
sau đó đi ạ
nhà
mình có thể là thế chỗ cũng được đó
season tại đi thử xe Mina gì không Và
đang ai từ đây hỏi axit tùy ý ở đó nói
là một tấc À cái sân của mình vẫn tồn
tại các bạn sẽ thắc mắc các bạn sẽ thắc
mắc theo kiểu này hôm trước anh bảo lại
xin đưa kiểu đó mình chỉ còn Tắt trình
duyệt đi là là được rồi mà là là season
sẽ tắt mà đúng ạ Tại sao Xuân này vẫn
còn máy anh từ hôm đấy đến giờ chưa ta
là không Mình còn vừa reset lại máy cơ
chứ tại sao điều này xảy ra bởi vì chỉ
đơn giản một điều thôi đó là ờ con
Server này học con server mà mình đang
mở
về bản chất nó lại chưa từng được tắt nó
đi Em hãy cần gì thế
Ừ nếu mà còn stop ở đây xong rồi
stop Ở Đây Rồi sát lại thì cái này Mỹ
tắt còn mùa khi server của mình B máy à
mày không ạ Để em có sợ vợ à vợ thật
không như thế
ở tỉnh thì nó sẽ già sẽ hết
anh nói chung bị Ok
Ừ thì bây giờ là season có rồi không ạ
Mình cứ luôn để xin xác định trên cơ nhé
và chỉ cần bà chỉ được phép restart một
lần nữa nha các bạn xin sát 2 lần sẽ vào
lỗ đấy mà như này
chưa Okay tiếp theo là bây giờ Sistar
rồi Các bạn thấy có đăng nhập rồi nếu
đăng nhập rồi thì anh ấy ở đây nút không
phải đăng nhập đăng kí nữa mà phải đăng
xuất thôi ông ạ thì cái Menu là mình
phải sửa lại một tí Mình sẽ có phép về
đây này kiểm tra lại Nếu mà ít MT là nếu
trống cái xuân ai đi ạ tất cả nếu mà cho
đăng nhập không ạ Ừ thì mình sẽ hiển thị
là những cái này bảo như thế này
à à em
tắt đi đây
pp pp trẻ con eo thì đó ngày này à
em thật sự đây đăng xuất lại
đây sẽ xa lắm ạ
đó các bạn sẽ xảy ra nó sẽ bị mất cái
đăng nhập đăng ký đi bây giờ chúng đăng
xuất các bạn hãy thêm với chào được
bộ loa kéo cho đầy đủ assistant là
nên lời đó ngoại
chào như này sẽ phải trả cho chồng về sự
nghiệp
Ừ ngoan Ok chưa
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ có thêm gần nút thêm
vào giỏ hàng không ạ thêm vào giỏ hàng ở
đây sẽ là
EX3 FPT này
em ngược lại với em đi nếu không giống
ai đi trước à Mình có thể đạt được hàng
à
cho
mình đặt mình thêm vào giỏ hàng đứng như
cũng dựa theo ID sản phẩm thôi ở đây sẽ
là
áp two cards em ạ ạ
xe tải nhẹ chống về hợp lý mà
bạn ơi Không phải xem chi tiết nữa rồi
sẽ là thêm vào giỏ hàng
và đây Các bạn hãy thêm hệ biết rồi đi
nó xuống dòng đi
ở đâu ạ bấm vào này sẽ thêm vào giỏ hàng
này em mình sẽ tạo file này
em phải thật ra không cần hiển thị gì cả
pha ngày chỉ cần đơn giản là xử lý thôi
Thế cái mình đã từng nói vụ là xử lý
thêm vào giỏ hàng này thì mình sẽ làm
việc với season chúng mình không làm
việc với tao bây mình không làm việc với
lô cổ tourists thì còn làm vừa có key mà
mình sẽ làm việc với
season tất cả đương nhiên phải có khi xa
rồi đóng lại
cái bài toán ở đây trước khi trước khi
cốt mình xin phép là mã giả vì để các
bạn dễ hình dung bài toán nó sẽ có những
trường hợp và nào xảy ra trường hợp đầu
tiên chỉ ở một
là khi chưa có gì trong giỏ hàng
thì thì khi mà các bạn thêm sản phẩm vào
đúng ạ được tiền thêm sản phẩm vào giỏ
hàng
khi chịu gì trong tọa nó không ạ thì bạn
sẽ chỉ đang giả thêm thêm nó Hoan hô ấy
đúng ạ
có thêm vào đã tính đã nhảy sang bên
thanh toán chưa chưa đồng ngoại chỉ dán
thêm vào ra ok thêm
mã sản phẩm vào đông ạ ok
Ừ từ mình
ạ Bây giờ giả sử là mình có bây giờ mình
gặp
à mình dùng từ sản phẩm từ tao không
đúng lắm thử thêm bút và giỏ hàng đi
thêm bút vào Okay đây tiếp theo là
trường hợp 2
Thêm muối vào thì cái này dễ rồi nhưng
giờ sự là mình lại thêm bút vào giỏ hàng
phát nữa Đây là hai lần một nhé lên thêm
lần 2 thì nó không vào trường hợp một nó
vào trường cấp 2 rồi đó là khi có gì
trong rõ Hà
Đông ạ Thì bây giờ mình bắt đầu lại
Ừ thì mình sẽ lại thêm bút vào thêm bút
vào Ok đúng ạ nhưng thực ra thế này
không đúng nữa của vì à
Ừ cái này mình không cần phải thêm nó
nữa mà mình chỉ cần tăng số lượng sản
phẩm thôi tăng số lượng bút đấy theo ý
hiểu các bạn ấy như thế thêm cùng bút và
mà không ạ nhưng con thật ra cái đoạn
này nó phải là tìm trong giỏ hàng
có bút chưa
nếu có rồi thì tăng lên một
phần là như thế này với sao bây giờ sự
là mình thêm sách và giỏ hàng em ạ
à à
Ừ thì rõ ràng là nó nó khuya vẫn có gì
trong do hàng không ạ cho nó trường hợp
3 hiểu về thế
chợ hoa trường hợp hạ được các bạn của
trường vào mạng được
Ở đây có khi gặp phải trường hợp hay đi
thêm vẫn là khi có gì không chở hàng nhé
và tìm trong giỏ hàng
em có sách chưa đóng ạ
thì đây nếu có rồi tăng lấy một còn nếu
chưa ra Nếu chưa thì thêm vào
đúng ạ Cái kiểu kiểu nha mình đã làm
được mã giả rồi nha các bạn có thể thấy
cái này thực là có bạn thì thấy mã già
này còn khó hiểu hơn khi cốt ở bên mình
cốc thì không biết là các bạn có hiểu
được không
Ừ Ok nói chung và bây giờ mình cần là
mình mình thấy mình truyền cái ID lên
trưa nay đi vào trong rõ hàng thì mình
cần lấy lại ID đã cái đấy đưa tiên cần
đã không ạ Đi vòng dollar get ID này
thì mình phân biệt sản phẩm này Sản phẩm
kia quay đi ông ạ Diên hình như mình đã
nói thì mình sẽ có tách trường hợp là
kiểm tra rõ hàng có chưa đúng không ạ
thì ở đây mình sẽ là ít MT đôla
season như đặt tên là khác đi này là cái
giỏ hàng
à à
ý là khi có và eo đây là khi chưa đó như
này trong trường hợp lúc đầu là khi chưa
có gì trước đã thì xem bút và không ạ Ok
thêm thêm vào trong cái Cáp này ở đây
giả sử là thêm bút vào đây thêm ID và
này thì mày đi vào ok như này
ở đâu ạ
ạ sau đó lại ở cuối Tôi chả sự thôi à
Tôi dùng cái chỗ cũng được rồi xin lại
Cáp như này
để cho mấy bạn sẽ hình dung nhé Tại
trang Nếu thấy à quay đi là 7 thêm vào
là bảy Ok đúng không ạ Nhưng bây giờ tôi
thoát ra ngoài
ông ngoại
khi tôi bấm là cái 7 rồi tiếc bấm vào
này
Ừ nếu thấy vẫn là 7 chạy sao về lần này
lần này thì nó nghỉ và eo rồi khi có gì
rồi ông ạ
từ khi có đi rồi mình tặng bỏ qua vụ đấy
anh bình tĩnh bỏ qua đã ạ
dù mình đeo mình quay lại ấn vào những
cây số khác mà vẫn là 7 thì nó vẫn nghệ
và yêu đúng không ạ Ok thì bây giờ mình
thấy là cái trường hợp một này xảy ra
chỉ đúng 1 lần với cái vụ sẽ mút là thôi
không ạ gần như những trường khác thì
cũng ở trường nó pha rồi ông ạ thì mình
giữ xử lý trường hợp hay chiều Hay khi
có rồi thì mình sẽ là
nữ ca sĩ xinh như này lại cá tiếp này
Em ở đâu Mình phải kiểm tra chứ mình sẽ
là ít nếu có bút ở trong giỏ hàng chưa
đóng ạ Đây
vào đi Này đây xong chưa gặp nếu có nếu
chưa có đầu tiên là nếu có rồi đi nếu có
rồi đi thì mình cần tăng số lượng lên nó
không ạ cần tăng số lượng lên
thì mấy bạn ở đây sẽ thấy có vấn đề cần
biết tăng nó lên kiểu gì chẳng lẽ là
mình cho ID + + như này tăng nó lên
không đúng ạ mình cần ở đây cái mảnh của
mình nó sẽ cần lưu lại những cái này đây
để mình thử vẽ các bạn dễ hình dung
mạnh thì nó sẽ dùng để mặc vuông như thế
này
anh ở đây mạng nhé Nó sẽ là
tại ID giờ giả sử và 7 thì đúng ạ Mình
cần lưu lại số lượng của nó nó không ạ
số lượng
mình có thể lưu dạng theo ivalue như thế
này là sự lúc đầu số lượng là một như
ảnh được sau đó khi mình thêm sản phẩm
nữa cũng số lượng là cũng ai đi ở Bệnh
thì mình tăng nó lên làm hai rồi Cứ mỗi
lần số lượng 7 nữa mình tăng số lượng
lên còn nếu ai đi nó là tám lần ạ
thì mình sẽ kiểm tra nếu không có thì
mình sẽ cho nó lại một như này
anh được đâu ạ tạm thời cơ bản như này
đã ok thì ở đây mình sẽ gán ở đây nếu mà
Viết thì cậu như thế này thì mình sẽ gắn
ở đây đây là ai đi này vào đây lúc đó sẽ
làm một này sau đó thì đây kiểm tra
Ừ nếu mà
Ừ mình đang làm rất là từ từ đấy nhớ mà
có là không không chấm này
a deceased in tại Cát tại vị trí thử ID
này
tại cái đi bài này nếu có thì mình sẽ là
copy cả cụm này và tăng số lượng lên thì
này
Ừ ok Còn nếu là thêm số 8 nếu không có
ngược lại đúng eo thì mình sẽ có đôla
xin tạ ID
ê bà cho nó bằng một Đông ạ
Ừ ok thế à Các bạn có thể vì sao sẽ ghét
cái ít này lên trên này để cho hai cái
này có thể khớp cốt nhau về các bạn nó
hai thằng Các bạn thấy giống hết cốt
nhau mà ông ạ Nếu mình cứ bỏ qua bọn này
đã bên mình cứ tải lại cho anh đi
để tải lại trang
ea7 ra thế này lỗi gì
xin lỗi vì a nó không nhảy vào à
Ừ tao đợi tí
vì nó có đây này
ở đôla echo à
ở đó nó lỗi lỗi này Tại sao các bạn sẽ
giòn thứ 10 tại sao nó lỗi nhé Ừ
Cái lỗi này vì nó không tìm thấy cái
biến ai đi nè để tăng nó lên bởi vì đây
vì vậy vì cái mạnh lúc đầu mình quy ước
nó không lại phải là mạng nó là chỗ ấy
các bạn để ý kĩ lại mình đã dùng aijou
no chỗ ích với mình phải sửa lại cái mà
thường là tôi sẽ thường ấy chơi rồi tôi
sẽ tạo Seasons resort ở đây đã
khi họ season sẽ ăn xét lại đi mình sẽ
ăn xét cả cái mạng này để làm lại đi
đoạn này các bạn thấy hơi khó hiểu một
tí vì mình đang giảm mình đã giảm từng
rất là trợ từng từng từng bước một nghe
các bạn thấy nó hơi bị khó hiểu
mình tạo An xét cái này đi đã nhé Ăn xét
nó đi à
à À quên quên phải restart ở em sẽ quên
quên nhận ạ
ở vòng 16 bây giờ nó lỗi của kìa bây giờ
cái này nó đúng là Bến Thành mạng rồi
anh và không dùng ai cho được mình sẽ
dùng pin rồi nó ra
pin rồi để mà phù hợp việc là in cả
chuỗi cả mạng hay mọ in nhiều cái được
còn ê thôi chỉ đi được chuỗi Thôi đi
được Trỗi và số rồi
ăn mì ăn xét lại chạy này đó việc các
bạn thấy nó là mạng kiểu như này ok chưa
Nó làm A5 này một này bên mình thử bỏ ăn
xe đi nhé bị bón xét đi tải lại 51 lên
hai này Năm Lên Ba Này Ok Ok nghĩa cứ
mỗi lần mình thêm sản phẩm vào mình tài
lại trang và số lượng và tăng ok chưa ạ
rồi Tiếp theo mình Có thể bấm nào thêm
và giao hàng tại đây này đó thì các bạn
thấy là số lượng mà tao ta là cha cha
Ừ Ok chưa
à à
ở đó đây đây là cách cơ bản cơ bản việc
là làm việc với Mạc mạnh sẽ gồm key và
vero thức như này nghĩa là đây ID của ID
của sản phẩm có đầy số lượng của sản
phẩm đúng ạ thực ra mình không biết được
có nên dạy các bạn nó phức tạp hơn một
tí không là theo kiểu làm mạnh nhiều
chiều hoặc là kiểu gì gì đó nữa
anh không biết các bạn từng học mạng
nhiều chiều chứ nhỉ
những người bạn nãy giờ im lặng ngoan
không biết mấy thằng nghe có đau não lắm
không
ở cái đoạn này các bạn có thể chụp lại
nhé các bạn cốt ở nay có thể gộp lại với
thằng cha này
Cô mang thẻ ít
xe Lego play bạn nào muốn làm tắt hơn
nên hộp cái đoạn này lên là đủ
Ẩm Thực ra cái giỏ hàng là cái khó nhất
khó nhất như mình đã nói mà xơ cái mà
mình vừa dậy thì ra nó Các bạn có bạn
thấy kiểu làm việc với mạng rồi thì cái
này không thấy khó lắm Nhưng mà thường
là hồi đầu mình sẽ sinh viên Đó là nó là
mạnh hay chiều hoặc là nhiều chiều hơn
nó phức tạp hơn một tí
à à
thì nó sẽ làm chứ sao
Ồ thông thường làm à Cái vụ thêm số
lượng tùy ý đóng ạ thì
ăn thịt thường là các bạn làm à khi nhảy
sang bên Xem giỏ hàng Xem giỏ hàng thì
sẽ là bụng đấy đây đây Bây giờ Bây giờ
mình sẽ đây mình sẽ dạy các bạn Ok bây
giờ Ok mình cứ tạm dạy dễ nhai đó dễ
nghe trước rồi mình nhảy sang bên sen đỏ
hàng rồi mình sẽ bảo là cách tối ưu của
cái việc Xem giỏ hàng bằng cách sửa cái
này như thế nào Ok chị ạ Bây giờ nói cho
các bạn thế à mình thêm được như này
đúng không ạ Mình cần Xem giỏ hàng thì
như nào Okay ra sự Xem làm tình là view
captian ạ Có bạn xem thử nha hát Alo này
thì cái này bạn chắc là sen đỏ hàng
thông qua xin ông ạ Mình sẽ có Sistar
này à anh ở đây này
sau đó thì mình sẽ có cái rọ Hà mình sẽ
đặt tên nó là khát bằng đô lecithin tại
cái giỏ hàng đối ngoại để lấy cái giỏ
hàng về sau đó mình sẽ in cái giao hàng
trong cái ba mình sẽ là đây rồi cái hát
ở đây mình cần y những cái gì trong bảo
hành và sửa mình Ví dụ ở đây Nó là kiểu
mình sẽ đi nào tôi thử xô pi nhé
à à
vì thế mà do hàng này
khi đăng nhập nó bỏ quá đăng nhập đi
thế thôi nhớ Trang này không có đăng
ở Tây Tiến
ở đó mấy ông sẽ thấy da thêm sẵn một sản
phẩm giao hàng có thể tăng số lượng đây
này anh ở đây nó chỉ cho ông cộng trừ
như này nó có nó lại tra chứ nó không
cho nhập số lượng Đây cơ kể tiếp tục tìm
kiếm sản phẩm nha
Ừ
thôi Tôi tôi làm cho mấy ông dễ hình
dung à Trà Sư các bạn chưa Rồi mua hàng
đi ok Các bạn thấy ở đây nó sẽ hiển thị
những gì anh chị đã ảnh sản phẩm tên sản
phẩm có thể khuyến mãi đi kèm mình không
khuyến mãi Bỏ qua những sẽ sáng là có
ảnh tên báo giá ít nhất như thế và số
lượng của cái ý sản phẩm các bạn đã đặt
các bạn thì tăng giảm nó rộng và mình
cũng dậy các bạn theo cơ chế là cộng trừ
như này cháu dễ hay vì nhập số lượng vào
vì khách hàng nhập số lượng và nó điêu
lắm đấy thì nó tương đối như thế này để
ngoại số ở dưới sẽ hiển thị cái thông
tin của người nhận đóng ngoặc đơn đặt
hàng đúng đại khai như thế nhưng chị tập
tiên nữa Ok thì bây giờ mình cần ở đây
mình sẽ cần là mình sẽ in Lan thành dạng
bạc trong nó xấu hơn cái làm tí nhé sẽ
là cần à
mã sản phẩm là ảnh hoa ảnh
sau đó tên sản phẩm
sau đó thì giá
khi
số lượng các bạn thể hiển thị tổng tiền
ở ngay
ngày cụt cuối cũng được
Ê bà
ở cục xóa ạ Xóa soạn xóa cái sản phẩm
mới gọi do hàng không ạ nhân như thế
em còn đây phố ích này
a Cáp này các bạn nhớ cái cái mạng này
nhé cái mảnh này thì các bạn thấy cái
bên cái bên trái này nó chính là gì ạ
chính là ID của sản phẩm không ạ con cái
bên phải diện nó cái số lượng của sản
phẩm không ạ thì cái này nọ tương tự Thế
cái này sẽ là ai đi sản phẩm và đây sẽ
ra số lượng sản phẩm ở đây số lượng thì
ạ Con ti là số lượng nếu để ông bé ông
để tiếng Anh đấy Đấy sau đó thì mình sẽ
có thấy đồ đây in ra
xe Honda nữa mạnh thì đây bài toán in ra
thì mình thấy cho ở đây làm thế nào lấy
được cái ảnh của sản phẩm bây giờ thì
các bạn sẽ thấy ra à
Ừ cái bài toán ở đây nó sẽ phức tạp hơn
một tí nhá
Em làm thế nào lấy được ảnh sản phẩm
ngoại
số 1 là các bạn sẽ phải kết nổi lên đây
b để mà lấy dai ảnh sản phẩm theo cái ID
này đấy thì có 2 cách 1 là các bạn sẽ
phải lấy toàn bộ cái ID này selects ngay
từ đầu cái danh sách toàn bộ đi này sang
màu ra được cái mặt sau đó các bạn sẽ in
ra ở trong này nhưng thực ra thấy nó hơi
bị
có lúc ta mình thấy nó hơi phước à còn
hồi đấy thay mình dạy cách nó nhanh hơn
nhưng mà đúng là nó vòng lặp N lần có
bao nhiêu sản phẩm nói N lần truy vấn
vào trong B nó thực ra nó khi nó nặng
nhưng mà chắc là rõ hàng ít thì anh thấy
không có tâm thì phải toàn mới lắm nó sẽ
như sao
thì
mình cứ có phải kết nối con ếch không ạ
Mình sẽ cậu fr đây này FPT này
ô tô svideo này
cmax shock format khu đất này Where I'd
like to
như thế này street
anh bằng máy cây quay nha
Wao này
là lấy cho thằng đầu tiên này
là hồi đấy thầy mình dậy kiểu nông dân
để ngay có bao nhiêu Có bao nhiêu sản
phẩm trong trong trong giỏ hàng thì in
bình luận
thì mình sẽ in math này sóc lại alo đô
là x tại
ảnh photo thì phải cái này nằm trong
admin
fax photo rồi Vậy ạ
Anh ở mình sẽ review car đ.tp đúng không
ạ
ở đó Anh ấy hình như nằm trong khu đất
mà
Ừ tôi như là thêm chữ s
hình
ảnh hơi to quá mình sẽ chỉnh hay cho nó
bằng 100
Ăn tỏi ngay tiếc là anh sản phẩm mình
hôm nay mình để chung ông sao tí thêm
sản phẩm khác được ờ
khi đó ở đây sau đó thì mình sẽ có tại
khái thôi thế cho là ích Tại tên sản
phẩm không ạ là nên sau đó thì đây là
giá thì là fries ngoại
và thêm cái nữa là quantity số lượng
chính là want I
Ừ từ cái này Quân Thùy Chi
đó ra ok rồi số lượng 75 có vẻ đúng
Em hãy cho nó màu mày ăn tí lại bao đời
một với with 100 nhé
nó như này tổng tiền đấy được ra tổng
tiền thì các bạn Đơn giản thôi lấy cái
giá nhân với số lượng ra tổng tiền không
ạ sẽ là nhân với công ty ra tổng tiền
không ạ
em chia amin về u xơ có chứ Mình đang
dạy bên ạ
chú ý bạn là khách hàng đúng không Mình
đã dậy ăn Minh được khách hàng này thì
thôi không ạ Đấy tổng tiền nha các bạn
muốn hiển thị tiền như kiểu phẩy phẩy
phẩy các bạn tra về cái Hàn format money
họ format-number của TP là ra nhé đó thì
các bạn thấy ở đây nó có bị một nhược
điểm nhằm như mình vừa nói nó khó chịu ở
điểm là cô ấy mình khó chịu cực đó là
kiểu cứ mỗi lần
Ừ thứ nhất là khi vào trang lại xem thì
các bạn thấy là nó
thì nó sẽ selec
thì nó sẽ Shake Sao lại
lần này chạy vòng lập vòng lập có bao
nhiêu sản phẩm Chạy bấy như lần vòng lập
câu kết nối như thế này tệ gần nhất Thứ
hai là mình cứ tải lại sang này nó lại
chạy lại phát nữa là trải nghiệm thế này
mình nghĩ là mình nghĩ treo treo mình
nhá là không không đúng lắm Tôi thích nó
không hợp lý lắm thế Cái này có cái hai
điểm khi các bạn kiểm tra đi kiểm tra
lại việc giá của sản phẩm thể thay đổi
trong lúc mà Minh Đô mình đang đang đặt
ra thế nọ nó hơi sai mà tí vì thực Khách
hàng vừa nhìn giá ví dụ giảm xóc của anh
tám triệu thôi tự nhiên ấn thêm vào giỏ
hàng tại lại cho anh đấy thế nó lên 10
triệu
thì lúc đấy Đúng sắc thật đấy nhưng mà
chuẩn nhá theo lôgic và theo tôi giúp
người dùng hiểu ý đó Khi mà người dụng
thêm sản phẩm vào giỏ hàng rồi
từ lúc đầu nó có ảnh nó có cái ảnh hay
có cái giả giá như thế nào
sau khi mình bấm thêm thì nó cần khi
sang bên giỏ hạn nó cần phải giữ nguyên
như thế bởi theo quy tắc cả
anh theo quyền của khách hàng đúng à
Người ta đặt như thế nào thì người ta
phải nhận được như thế chứ không phải
nên tao đặt cái không tự nhảy sang trang
này nó thay đổi
à Thế à Tưởng là như mình nói là không
có thay đổi đâu mà việc không thay đổi
thì mình phải Tống tất cả những cái dữ
liệu này vào trong đâu mà trong ngay
ngay cái rọ hàng lúc mình đặt
ở bển mà khi mà khách hàng sang bên này
chỉ được in lại cái đồng đấy ra thôi chứ
không phải là mình cứ mỗi lần tả ngay nó
lại sẽ lách lại phát nữa trong đây b lần
mấy câu truy vấn
thì các bạn nhớ đến mi ngọn cha không
hiểu lắm thì bây giờ tôi sẽ thử làm theo
cách mà tôi không truy vấn nhiều như thế
này Cách vừa rồi Các bạn thấy thật là
thế này xong rồi ông ạ Cái này đưa giả
nhờ tôi không thích cảm này cơ thế kia
làm như kiểu khác thì sao thì đây sợ chị
mấy ông xe ôm
[âm nhạc]
à Thế bây giờ mình tên mình sẽ xóa cái
này đi
Xóa đi
anh không cần con nữa trong xong Card
này tôi không có tí con ếch nữa mà tôi
sẽ làm ở bên xử lý thêm vào giỏ hàng tôi
sẽ cần như thế này tôi sẽ biến này cái
này thành mạng hay chiều 223 chiều cũng
chẳng nhớ nữa
Ừ thôi chỉ biết làm việc mày nói tôi
không Nhớ hai bạn 223 chiều gì nhé Đây
cái này ID của sản phẩm cái số lượng thế
này là chưa đủ Tôi muốn cần cái này ID
sản phẩm cái này toàn bộ thông tin của
sản phẩm nó sẽ như này
Ừ cái này lại một mảnh nữa và nó sẽ chưa
có là nên là
iPhone nữa
sau đó đi I want it I là
bài
1 chẳng hạn sau đó thì photo là cái ảnh
ABC đúng không ạ abc chấm gg ạ và giá
Price đúng giá là 123 bạn đấy Và cứ mỗi
lần thêm lại cái sản phẩm này trong lọ
hàng thì mình kiểm tra xem là ID nó có
đúng không có đúng thì tăng số lượng lên
để ông ạ Còn toàn bộ những thông tin này
mình giữ nguyên Ok không ạ
ở đây là mà không hẳn ở dưới sân đây là
mạng thôi ông ạ Cái này cũng phải sửa
lại đúng không ạ sẽ ôm Nguyên về nó là
như thế này thật sự Cái này là iPhone
tao đúng không ạ thì giá rẻ hơn hoặc 12
càng thôi Ảnh khác đi có số lượng thì có
thể khác nóng lạnh đấy thì để mình làm
được cái này thì mình cần kết nối dp
ngay thử lúc mà thêm vào giỏ hàng nhưng
mà chỉ cần thệ chỉ cần đến kết nối vào
khi mà thêm giỏ hàng đúng một lần những
cái lần sau rồi các bạn tải lại cái
trang này hay tải lại cái rọ hàng thì nó
sẽ không Không cần phải kết nối B nữa để
cái hay để cải hay việc tôi bảo rồi đó
là khi mà thêm vào cho thêm vào giỏ hàng
như thế nào thì nó cân giữ nguyên thế
khi mà Xem giỏ hàng chứ phải khi Xem giỏ
hàng nó lại phải kết nối lại nó lấy lại
thông tin đôi khi thông tin thay đổi thì
người dùng trải nghiệm người dùng trên
toán không giờ tốt không ạ người dùng
khó chịu đấy từ trước khi ông làm như
cậu lại ông ông làm theo kiểu là ờ ờ
ở
dạng là sản phẩm Đấy nó đang dễ cháy
hàng nên không phải kiểm tra liên tục
trong DB là xe mà sàn vấn mấy con hài
không còn không thì không có lý do nào ạ
sản phẩm nó bị thay đổi thông tin khi mà
đã lên lên gian hàng rồi đúng không ạ Ok
mình nói rất là dài dòng nữa rồi Không
biết cảm nhận mình xin lỗi nhưng đại
khái nói như thế này
anh ở đây tôi sẽ cho ông ấy Ông làm như
thế này ạ
ở đây tôi tạo xóa cái rọ ạ Xóa cái giỏ
hàng đi ăn xét và đi này không ạ
anh ở đây vẫn là bài toán à khi chưa có
xe mình nghĩa mình góp được cái thằng
này nhé mình sẽ nộp luôn thằng này cho
các bạn cho nó nhắn này khi chưa có
sản phẩm đấy Trong đó hà không quan tâm
Do Hàng Trống nữa Một cái là có một cái
không có nhà
Tặng xóa này đi ăn sáng hàng ngày trong
mày đi Ok Ok
Ok khi chưa có sản phẩm nào trong giỏ
hàng tức là sản phẩm đây lần đầu tiên
xuất hiện trong giỏ hàng thì mình cần
kết nối đến B B đây rồi quite admin
có con ếch chấm pp sau đó thì mình sẽ có
sya điệp khúc Mà vừa nãy mình làm ở đấy
ở đây mình sẽ copy đoạn này cho nhanh à
à
Ừ đúng như này luôn này mình sẽ kết nối
dp để lấy thông tin sản phẩm này về sau
đó thì mình sẽ có
an toàn bộ thông tin sản phẩm này kèm
theo
cho nên này nêm này bằng đô la ex tại
nêm này
tiếp theo ở đây có ảnh đúng không ạ Ảnh
này à Ý giá này
ạ
sau đó thì bên cái số lượng
số lượng thì đương nhiên là lần đầu tiên
đạt thì mình sẽ cho nó bằng một thế xong
rồi Tiếp theo và ngược lại nếu mà khó
sản phẩm ở trong tỏ hành với thì sao thì
mình không cần kết nối b nữa mình không
cần làm một cái đoạn này nữa Mình chỉ
cần đơn giản đã copy cái này như thế này
đổi nó thành
+ + + tất cả tăng lên một thế ra sao
à à
ạ Bây giờ mình mình xin phép mình quay
lại bên là trang trang chủ
anh ấn vào thiên giỏ hàng đó mấy ông
thấy thấy thế này thì ra hơi khó nhìn
một tí tôi xin phép dùng cái hàng này để
cho mấy ông nhìn trông có vẻ dễ nhìn hơn
Ừ tôi có cài tiện ích thế nên làm với
ông sẽ sẽ nhìn hơn
Ừ nó lâu thế rất nhiều hơn không
em đẹp hơn cái này bên này thôi em ạ cứ
xóa bên này nha mày ông nhìn mới này nhé
Đây chính ạ đi còn sản phẩm này nên này
đó với tôi tại lại tra phát nữa này
không thấy có số lượng không ta đợi thì
tại sao số lượng đây không tăng
mục tiêu sai đấy
anh nói nhảy vào đây hai nhà ở đây ạ
Ừ nếu mà không có thì tăng số lượng lên
đúng rồi
Ừ tí nhớ lại tí nha
à À đúng rồi tôi ăn xét ai quên quên
quên quên bỏ đi bỏ đi Cứ mỗi lần tắt nó
đi chứ Đúng rồi tiện ích reason viewer
Bạn ghi nhớ với À nó xin đi trễ cà One
Piece tại tra này
một số lượng lớn hay nhỏ đó ba tôi thử
sang bên trang khác bấm vào sky ơi này
đó
a cho bạn xem này số lượng một số lượng
hát Ok chưa
ở đó thế được rồi đúng không ạ Bây giờ
mình chỉ việc đơn giản là gì xanh bây
giỏ hàng mình in toàn bộ những cái trong
tổ hàng ra ta xong đấy
Ừ thì bây ở bên tỏa hàng xóm loại này đi
xóa bạn Kết nối đi đổi toàn bộ cái này
cái này thì vẫn là ai đi sản phẩm cái
này sẽ là ích à Tại từng sản phẩm từng
sản phẩm tại I want it I ngoại
thân sản phẩm entity như thế này cho tôi
sẽ review cáp thì bị ông xe này
ở đó Ok chưa
á cái điện đầu tiên thì có bạn thắc mắc
một tí và lại tôi dùng hàm print pro để
mày in cái mạnh ra nó lại in thông tin
của cả cái mặt nó có thêm chữ Android
các bạn để ý Có thêm cho Android không ạ
ấy là sự tôi cho các bạn xem lại cái đấy
nhá Tôi in hai phát đi một cái là hả
Thôi tôi phải ấn cái á dùng pin rồi Các
bạn xem nhé ạ
à à
thì tại sao này các bạn thấy nó thêm
Idol thêm cho Android giới thiệu nó Mạnh
này sau đó thì in ra kiểu này đấy của pp
in bình thường nhưng mà còn cái tiện ích
này thì nó sẽ là phù hợp để in ra cái
cái dữ liệu reason và Ừ rồi tôi gọi E
Trâu nó ra dạng dây sân cái mảnh này
thôi biến nó thành dạng dưới sân đó tôi
nó ra thì nên là nó hiển thị được đẹp
như thế với thời gian nếu mà các bạn nó
tự những ngày đi Tôi thử và bọn ẩn danh
bí ẩn danh tội cũng đang mở rồi mở yeah
đi chắc là nó không cài cái gì cả
Đã đến lúc lỗi mày ra rồi
Đã lâu lắm rồi không nhắc đến mày cái
thì nó sẽ trông như thế này các bạn sẽ
thấy à cái cái dấu ngoặc vuông của tôi
biến thành dấu ngoặc nhọn bỏ vì reason
nó sẽ hiểu lại dữ liệu nó thành dạng đối
tượng thì nên là Ngọc Ngọc qua này một
một ngọn Thực ra là các bạn vì sau các
bạn làm việc làm lập trình viên là các
bạn kiểu định phải quen về đối tượng và
quen với việc à
A Reason nhiều các bạn làm việc với
Lysin rất nhiều Nó là kiểu hiển thị ra
dữ liệu thôi đấy thì các bạn đương nhiên
phải cài thêm cái tiện ích để mà xem
được dữ liệu đấy ông ạ
à à
ở
đây Đúng rồi chắc sáng này tôi chẳng cài
cái gì cả cứ Nó sẽ hiển thị ra kiểu rồi
Kiểm không ạ Thôi I
Ừ Ok Đấy nói chỗ nào mấy ông thầy đó số
lượng tăng các thứ thứ là cái bên này
các bạn thấy chẳng cần phải xử lý không
cần kết nối dê bên đấy Cái tôi phải ngon
không cần kết nối dp nữa không ạ Và cốt
bên này các bạn sẽ hiểu rồi nhá Nếu mà
không có sản phẩm nào trong giỏ hàng thì
kết nối DB lấy dữ liệu sản phẩm đấy cập
nhật dữ liệu sản phẩm đấy vào trong giỏ
hàng thôi còn nếu mà có rồi thì tăng số
lượng lên một đống ạ Nhưng mà thực ra
lúc đầu tôi không dạy các bạn như này
được không phải dậy từng bước từng bước
như thế mày ông hiểu không ạ Ok
Bây giờ thì
anh giống như ai bảo Tôi tin là thay đổi
số lượng ở đây thay đổi số lượng ở đây
thì tôi sẽ có thêm cái nút giống như
thằng Cellphone S vừa rồi nó làm thêm
cái note và ra là cốt nó cũng đều nhanh
cốt Tôi tên là tiền sẽ Em thấy a
ở đây tôi thường phải thêm dấu trừ dấu
cộng được nhưng nó luôn Thế à Đây bấm
bây giờ sự là thư Hà Đông
thì mình sẽ là
Ừ tôi thường hay làm nha Để tôi chỉ mày
ôm cách mà
cho em
đọc đấy Đi rửa bát đi update quan tivi
Em in card đó trong cho chuyên nghiệp đó
số chuyên
ai đi tới nhiều chuyện ai đi sản phẩm để
mình biết ở mình cập nhật sản phẩm nào
vậy cũng được sản phẩm
không phải tất cả sản phẩm không ạ ạ
Ừ
mình hiểu Bấm vào đây mình sẽ là cập
nhật số lượng của sản phẩm mã vàng 7 ở
trong giỏ hàng ngoại
à à
Cho
hỏi bạn kia hỏi đúng cái mình đang định
chạy luôn season start này làm việc với
chiếc sừng của tôi start không ạ sau đó
thì lại làm việc với đôla ghé lấy thông
tin về sau đó thì ở đây mình ở đây nó
lại có hai trường hợp xảy ra đó là
mình mình phải kiểm tra xem mà số lượng
của sản phẩm nó đang làm ấy đã Hôm trước
mình nhớ có trang nào nó trừ nó thành âm
12 âm hay vẫn vẫn được vẫn chưa nghĩa là
khi các bạn chưa đến mức số một rồi còn
chưa đến phát nữa thì các bạn đã xóa ơi
đúng không ạ
anh không vừa nãy mình có nói được ra
làm cái input 253 ấy là thực ra mình khó
vay để được có kiểm tra được người dùng
nhập rất nhiều cái có hệ nó nhập Tình Ta
tinh mình phải ba đến nó
thì các bạn vừa thấy thằng Cellphone S 5
mẫu này đúng nó dụng thẻ thôi mấy ông
thích thì mấy ông có thể tự mùi mò với
cái vụ làm kiểu kia tôi thôi làm theo
lại thẻ cho nó dễ
Ok thì à Ở đây có hai trường hợp mà vừa
tôi tôi có nói vào ra trường hợp mà khi
số lượng nó mạnh một thì mình cần xóa nó
đi khỏi rõ hàng chứ không phải mình đổi
số lượng hàng không này số lượng này là
một ông ạ Còn hai là trường hợp mà số
lượng lớn hơn 1 thì mình chiến hả - thôi
ông ạ Mình sẽ ít Ở đây ít lotion tại cáp
tại cái ảnh vị trí từ ID lại con Ti
bằng bằng 1
U23 dù bằng ở chắc sẽ chọn nó chỉ là mua
thôi thì mình sẽ cần ăn xét là xóa đi
ông ạ
Ê mày có thể làm ngược lại nhé mày không
thể kiểm tra khác một trước tôi thích
làm kiểu này số lượng đây tao ở đâu chưa
trừ đó Thế là sao
Ừ ok các bạn có thể đầu tiên thì các bạn
thử chạy đã
em chạy không không thấy lỗi gì cả các
bạn mới cho ăn sẽ hết đơ về
location
à mình thể quay lại bên tư khác trong TP
này à
Chúng tôi ăn xét mà mẹ à Tôi ăn xét nhầm
nội ăn xét một con Ti ăn xét ở đây phải
bay cả cái sản phẩm à đi theo ai đi chứ
không phải con đi cái bị say mất rồi
I - văn nữa này
khi
sử dụng đấy xe hơi chạy bằng bằng một
thời đã nó lỗi có thể ngược lại cũng
được cho nó để làm chiều ngược lại
à à
vì số lượng tháng 1 - -
Anh phải vào làm nha lớn hơn 1 thì - còn
không thì xóa đi để chắc nhất bùm đó là
nhầm lắm bạn ơi đây máy bơm được
ở đó
Ừ đúng rồi cuối buổi cho sẽ chia sẻ cái
đồ ăn cũ rồi Đã làm à bế tôi không xem
lại xem là tôi lưu lại muốn Cũng ở mục
nào nữa ừ
Ừ anh không người lại để buổi sau nóng ạ
buổi hôm nay có kia không có nhiều thứ
cần lắm
dự án trở đây này
32 ok
A1 anh bay gọi cho con gì cả Không ạ Nếu
mà không còn gì cản như này thì mới ông
lên nữa hiển thị là giỏ hàng trống gì đó
mày có thể mấy ông ấy thì kiểm tra ít MT
rồi cát rồi đây nếu mà nếu mà không Nếu
mà trống thì mình sẽ hiển thị ra cậu bạn
cần cần thêm cái gì đó chứ đi xem trang
này đúng không ạ Cái gì đó Bây giờ thứ
ba tôi bảo rồi Các trải nghiệm người
dùng không tốt tốt khi mà không hiển thị
cái máy nổ đây lại hàng chục không ạ lại
phải xóa tay ngay
vì thế mà do hàng này
xe tải thêm vào giỏ hàng Ok Thế bây giờ
quay bên phía cát để làm tính năng sửa
là + giỏ hàng thì như nào Đấy do mà Mấy
ông để ý kĩ là tôi
Ừ thôi Làm ở đấy tôi là tên là update
onette không phải là decrease in Grid là
tăng hay giảm vì méo để chỉ đây nhá cơ
bản chất ở đây mình sẽ quan tâm việc bà
Ờ Ờ nó đi làm cập nhật số lượng chẳng
qua nó thay đổi kiểu kiểu một cái kẹo
lại sửa một cái kiểu là cậu nên tôi sẽ
thêm cái tham số ở đây cũng được nó là
em hay bảo ở đây mình sẽ có thai đây là
- lại đi click
cộng lại in Grid Nếu mà không biết tiếng
Anh
đi criers inquiries cộng nhà anh tưởng
nhưng
anh ở bên này mình sẽ là lấy cái thai về
thôi
vào đây lại ít hay bằng bằng bằng tikz
ra à
khi xử đúng ạ thì này
khi con eo đấy
+ + + những này có sóng
Em
hãy rất nhanh
Ê mày không tin nữa để tôi thử mày không
xem nhé
Ai Cập
ta có Ừ Ok chưa
à à
ở lại thế đường đúng ạ Nhà em sẽ là lấy
cái hay về kiểm tra xem mà nó là chỗ
cộng hai chứ nó tăng giảm nó thôi Hồi
trước tôi còn yêu cầu sinh viên làm nó
kiểu không được phép hiểu đặt vì hôi đấy
Thằng đấy làm mà à à nếu không chọn đề
tài đừng nói chọn đề tài mình cái gì đó
nó không thể xảy ra viện bông nhé Mấy
ông bây giờ kể cả dịch dã nào mấy ông
không nói chuyện đặt ô tô online rồi đạt
được 10 trước cùng một lúc lâu nhé
Cài đặt độ tối online bởi chiếc cùng lúc
Ô tô đồ chơi anh không không không quên
chuyện đấy đâu nhá nó cũng không có
chuyện thực ra ông để chi cái gì ở tiền
tỷ mày không phải đã lo lắm không đặt 10
cái rồi ông đặt có mạng luôn like đố vui
à đúng không Không thử cả
đấy thì tôi yêu cầu là khi mà thêm số
lượng vào kiểm tra là kiểu số lượng hơn
phép lớn quá thì đó chẳng hạn thì mấy
ông thể ít theo trong này đấy à
ở chung nhà mình về sau tôi kiểu gì cũng
sẽ làm đám vài ông người cách chọn đề
tài nhưng mà đến lúc bảo vệ thôi mày ném
cơ mà ông cứ cẩn thận
Hồi trước có cái vụ mà Hồi trước có vụ
đã
Ừ ông đấy Chọn làm trang web Cho thuê
truyện tranh ok rồi thấy tiền ship quá
luôn cả tiền thuê trong đấy à thận sẽ
tiền thuê còn đắt hơn tiền mua chuyện
chứ
số tiền ship cộng với tiền thuê đất thần
tiên mua mua sửa nhanh à
Ê mày cho con Mẹ không đặt phải nghĩ đề
tài không thiết thực một tí
Hà Tĩnh
anh không cần chuyện rồi đấy nhớ ông ấy
để có mỗi 15.000 quyển xong rồi Facebook
3.000 thôi tiền ship 10.000 nữa
Ừ ok đại khái như thế này thôi Hơi lan
man quá rồi Mày làm từ nó xóa nha Xóa
thì sẽ là sao đi chạy đêm để xóa đây tôi
sẽ thể à Đây đây
là xóa thường tôi để dụng ích nào dễ anh
hiểu Xóa mình sẽ là đây đi tiếp hả
ơi con có tên nó như này cũng được
thì mình sẽ là ai đi về cho lại đi nha
Thì cái hạn thôi Cái này nó khá là nhắn
nó chỉ đơn giản là ăn xét nữa thôi
à à
Ừ
cái này một trong những file mà sinh
viên Tôi rất thích ơi dậy sớm ngắm xin
step này ai đi bằng gà trắng cập
Birthday bằng đôla get hay đi này sau đó
thì ăn xét nó nó sẽ xem tại khác Tại ai
đi nhé Xong rồi
à à
em xóa hết đồ quay lại nữa sao hết đâu
đúng không ạ
nhưng mà như tôi đã nói thì mày ông có
gì cấp chưa cần lại làm header vội đâu
nhé Cái ông cứ cốt đúng hết đã kiểm tra
lại đến hôm gần cuối các bạn hết đâu lại
được không sao bấm vào này em có bay bay
ngoại kê ấy nói chung là mấy ông vừa rồi
thấy toàn bộ tôi đã dậy mà ông xong
tương đối với cái giỏ hàng
Ê mấy ông còn có thể thêm cái nút là nút
xóa cả cái rọ hàng thì bản chất là nó sẽ
chuyển xét cái đua Xin Cát này thôi hay
bị đội đổi ID bay luôn cái cát này Nhưng
mà khi các bạn làm bay cái giỏ hàng như
thế thì các bạn quay lại đây nó sẽ bị
lỗi đấy Các bạn khỏe để sẽ bị lỗi thì
lúc đấy làm gì trong dọn Hà nữa không ạ
ạ
khi nghe các bạn hãy kiểm tra MT ở đây
cho chắc chắn nhá hoa khi các bạn mới Và
cái trang này lúc đầu thật sự khách hàng
mới vào trang này lần đầu sẽ bị lỗi như
này cũng tương tự Giống như mình vừa nói
là khi đã bấm xóa cả có hành ra cái đoạn
này vào cái lập tức vào nó sẽ lỗi luôn
nha thì các bạn như mình đã nói cái đấy
liên quan Violet các bạn phải làm vài
biết là kiểm tra đây ít theo cái thứ
nhiều vào bởi vì hôm đấy hôm bảo vệ rồi
thôi ngoài để trong bé ông tự để mô tôi
sẽ tôi sẽ bắt mấy ông bấm loạn xạ và lên
và còn rất nhiều cái Hoài ăn Tôi sẽ bắt
mấy ông thứ bấm vào mấy ông sẽ thấy way
to a cực kì toàn
Chúng tôi sẽ kiểm tra Virut của mấy ông
cũng rất là chắc anh nhá ví dụ là tôi
cho mấy ông thêm sản phẩm ID tôi đây thử
ví dụ
Ừ ông nhớ trước thì nhớ nhé có lợi cho
bé ông ấy Tôi còn đang nghĩa về sau của
tôi cho mấy ông bảo vệ online được tin
là mấy ông bảo vệ đầu bị ném đá nỗi mà
ông bảo vệ đằng sau sẽ rút kinh nghiệm
Nhưng kiểu gì cũng sẽ bị ném đá bằng gái
khác thôi đây tôi tôi cho là sử đây nếu
Để ý kỹ nha đừng Linh ở đây là ai đi
bằng 70 hãy copy đường link IDM bệnh này
có tăng nó vòng 710 ra
đấy lỗi Đúng không cho rằng lỗi rồi ông
ạ Tại sao lỗi như thế này để sẵn thế
Anh ấy thì thì làm thế nào làm mấy ông
chắc chắn nó không được phép để một cái
lỗi này xảy ra đấy để việc virus của mày
không đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ em cứ vào trang này là lỗi này phải rõ
ràng bây giờ thêm vấn đây rồi đấy
ok
Bây giờ mình thử tưởng tượng đối xong
cái giỏ hàng đấy mình sẽ ghét ta sang
bên ta
ở bên này là qua một tí việc kế đồ ăn
ừ ừ
ở đầu tiên thì mình mình nghĩ là tự đánh
giá mình cái trang web các bạn Mình có
đồ ăn các bạn thì mình sẽ thêm một vài
tiêu chí hiểm như đội ăn ý nhất này em ạ
giao diện đẹp nhất thì tôi bảo tôi không
quan tâm giao diện lắm đâu nhưng mà còn
nhiều hoang làm cho diện đấy cãi hiện
đội sẽ đổ lỗi cho cái này vào giải an ủi
trải nghiệm người dùng tốt nhất cái giao
diện đẹp thì chưa chắc là dễ rung nóng ạ
trải nghiệm người dùng mà lại từ đầu đến
cuối có vẻ là ổn ngoạn vân vân vân cố
gắng nhất của nhanh nhất làm chưa Tôi sẽ
xét các nhóm là lại lúc đầu tôi thấy yếu
nhưng mà sau còn thời gian tôi thấy lại
nói chung là tiến bộ được bởi vì hồi mà
tôi dậy thôi em ở Dạy
cái này lại tâm sự một tí hồi ở trường
nó dậy thật ra hồi đầu tôi dậy tôi bị
nạn lắm Bởi vì sinh viên trường tôi nó
Anh nói thật thì tôi Tôi bảo ở ra trường
Tôi ở trường tư và nó cũng gần như là
cao đẳng thành ra là chất lượng đầu vào
của sinh viên nó hơi không Không được
xịn như ở đại học chính quy nó không có
tuyển vào gì cả ông nào cũng được vào
ông nào được học bổng như vậy em đặt
hàng tốt nhất đang ngồi cạnh tôi nó còn
đang được học bổng
Ừ thì đủ biết được cái chưa Mới tệ nha
cậu chỉ muốn sinh viên và thôi rồi Thế
học phí Đắt ấy sẽ nói chung nhà nghị
nhưng mà thấy gì không phải chất lượng
dậy mà không ra gì
và đặc biệt là cái quan điểm của thầy
tôi thôi Đấy nói các thầy khác đó là các
thầy đừng bao giờ đặt nguyện vọng cao và
sinh viên theo kiểu là anh không thể là
làm thứ nhất là không mong bọn nó là
siêu nhân ngay từ lúc vào trường để mà
các thầy dạy Ngàn Cả không chuyện đấy
nói thẳng là bọn nó trượt hết các trường
đại học bọn nó bị lừa mới vào được đây
Nói thẳng như thế tôi còn thấy bị lừa
rồi đấy mà thì thì các thầy không thể hi
vọng được cả bọn nó sẽ rất sắc bọn nó
còn thật chứ không muốn học đấy nhưng mà
không được phép khiến cho bảo nó quay
lại chửi trực thì mới điều không
Ừ tối chị nhất nóng ạ nó mặc quay lại
chửi thầy cái người thầy mà dậy mình và
thẳng thắn trả gì thì nói chung đã Đấy
là lỗi các thầy không ạ nghĩa là mình
phải làm nha Mình không phải chiều nó mà
mình sẽ phải đúng dạy học cho họ và dậy
nó không gọi từ số 1 thành số 10 đáng là
đại học chính quy thì nó là không làm
được việc siêu nhân đấy ông ạ thì mình
sẽ Mình chỉ quan điểm việc là dậy sinh
viên đang từ một nó Ít nhất nó phải lên
hàng hay đấy là cái ít nhé
Ừ đúng ạ đội bóng tiền đóng tiền ở đây
và nó kẹo tốn thời gian nữa đây thì tín
ngưỡng ở nó phải đạt được mới gì đó phải
cải thiện luôn cái gì đó
Ừ cái quan điểm đấy gọi thầy tôi hồi
trước là như thế thực cảm thấy thấy tôi
nói chung mà là một người kiểu có tư duy
có tầm nhìn và nói được người khác là
như thế
anh thấy kiểu nói mày Cái đấy thì ai
cũng thấy nó đúng thôi ông ạ chẳng ai ý
kiến gì nữa Chẳng iPhone làm được sinh
viên mình đuổi học sinh viên mình giúp
vân vân vân
Ừ mà tự nhiên đến giờ tôi tâm sự tự
nhiên lượt xem Tăng ca đấy
có hại của Dinh post chỉ rồi ok
nhưng mà Mấy ông hiểu gì tôi không ạ
nghĩa là
xe Toyota không mong tất cả các nhóm đều
thành xuất sắc khi mà tôi dậy xong tôi
mong tất cả các bạn đều cố gắng hết sức
để đạt được một cái sản phẩm đó và tôi
rất ghi nhận việc là tất cả các bạn cùng
tiến bộ lên Thế nên là cái nhóm cố gắng
nhất mà cái nhóm mà đang từ số 1 có lên
hình số 2 số 3 đó là cố gắng nhất của vì
nó là số 1 mà còn trụ được đến phút cuối
để bảo vệ Nó là siêu nhân rồi còn nếu mà
những cái ông mà đang dõi sẵn đang ngồi
ở đây này mà đang từ số 9
Ê thằng bé không chỉ đến 10 thì tôi
không quan tâm đâu Tôi không đánh giá
cao cũng được về rồi nên là mấy ông bởi
Nếu là siêu nhân sẵn rồi tôi không cần
tôi dậy thì mới là siêu nhân thôi chúng
ăn thì tôi không quan tâm mấy ông mà tôi
quan tâm à
ô tô quan tâm những cái ông mà chưa biết
tí gì nhiều người học của tôi mời ông
kiểu cố gắng dân mà ông ấy biết được là
mấy ông ấy yếu mà Mấy ông vẫn cố gắng
Đông ạ
Còn mấy ông mà tụt thì vứt học xong tôi
thì đúng là mấy ông
Ừ tôi không biết có phải lỗi của tôi
không nhưng mày sẽ chắn là có lỗi của
mấy ông chứa mấy ông để bản thân mình
tụt mà vẫn còn tốn nhiều thời gian như
thế
các bạn Nhóm em xin chuyển bảo vệ sinh
đợt 2 thì em có bị đẩy theo không không
không được ơi cuối tuần này sao mình
phải sắp xếp lại một vài nhóm đấy bởi vì
à Thật là một loài nghe hơi quá như thế
ra có 12 nhóm thì đúng có vài bạn thì có
vài bạn thì bị ghép tự nhiên cũng có vấn
đề gì đó mà chua hoặc 12 tuần đầu mà
chắc các bạn cũng đang phải
anh đang hơi bị cân nhắc về việc là có
nên tiếp tục làm hay không mình không
trước mình có nói với ban
ủy ban cán bộ Đó là kiểu thức là là
nhiều người rút nhiều nhất đó là 23 tuần
đó và 23 dân cuối
à Còn giữa dựa thì người ta đang làm dở
người ta không bỏ đâu nhưng mà đến gần
cuối thì các bạn sẽ bị có thể bị Na yêu
kiểu là ngồi Thế bây giờ vẫn chưa xong
rồi cái gì mà sắp bảo vệ được áp lực các
thứ có thể nghĩ chuyện bọc đấy à
anh vào nhóm kiểu gì á Các bạn à Đăng ký
nhá đăng ký Linh ở mình lại quên ghi cái
đường Linh rồi đây để mình đi nhé anh
em đăng ký làm đồ án
cho
các bạn nếu đăng ký lần này sẽ được hay
đấy ạ
em làm đợt 2 sẽ là mùng 1 tháng 1 mình
sẽ sắp xếp các thứ mình đang nghĩ là
chắc là sẽ có 2 đợt thôi mà về sau sẽ
cân nhắc sau Nhưng mà nhiều được quá thì
tôi chạy theo mấy ông cũng mệt nữa tôi
nghĩ à tại thế thôi những bạn quá sau
coi như là mất cơ hội tạo mới thế Tôi
không biết được chứ Khi về sau mấy ông
đông hơn mà ứng dụng dụ dỗ được tôi tự
xem xét
cho nên là mấy ông cũng cảm thấy mình
may mắn đi không ạ
em có một bạn gái nam thiếu người đấy
nhưng mà tôi đang
Ừ tôi cứ tôi cứ bí mật với không nói gì
cả
em ở chỗ nhóm thì sẽ ghét hai người
không ạ
nên nên là hai người
à à
ừ ừ
xe máy xúc là thứ hai tới này tôi nói
tôi sẽ có bất ngờ cho bạn thấy cái bạn
nữa Tôi vừa nói hi vọng cái bất ngờ đấy
nó sẽ xảy ra
có một người to A đúng rồi tôi có ghi
thêm một vài cái ở đây đó là một vài cái
câu qua một vài tính năng sao mấy ông có
thể cân nhắc làm xong cái đồ ăn nhá ra
mấy ông có thể đề xuất thêm để suốt thêm
nhắn tin riêng họ nhắn ở đây được thôi
để xem một tôi sẽ cho thêm ở đây nhé
những cái tính năng này nó tương đối
không đến nỗi khó quá thì mấy ông có thể
là những cái nào mà khó quá tôi sẽ ghi
vào đó ngoài đâu
các bạn có gì bạn cứ hỏi đi ngoại bây
giờ là hết giờ hết giờ dậy cái nước rồi
bây giờ sẽ hỏi đáp nữa cả chia sẻ thôi
em có cấp bằng gì không ạ
Ừ rồi online thôi không được Tôi không
được gì thôi ah nhưng mà còn chút là tôi
bảo rồi tôi sẽ thường trông tràng pháo
tay với 10 cái mới cái tài liệu nói cho
nó những cái gì có thể chia xe cho mấy
ông rủ mày không đi ăn được đi cà phê
cũng được những gì tôi thể làm được
Ừ tôi có thật này ông thích bóc lồ gì
tùy ông ạ Ừ Chứ giờ bảo tôi bằng cấp gì
tôi có đăng ký không nói chung mà không
đăng ký một cái gì cả thì chẳng có bằng
cấp gì đây viết giấy tay à dưới tay kèm
chữ ký à
khi import file Excel vào trong DB cũng
được nhưng tính năng này hơi khó lắm hơi
khó đấy đoán một này mình không biết các
bạn làm được không em mình rất thích và
hay sao
Anh An ninh bạn nhé
Ừ thôi có khi hả mày ông thích mấy ông
tự làm đi tôi không để cái sao đấy đâu
đây đâu Ông đọc mạch công ấy ngồi Tìm
hiểu về hết sự thời gian làm mấy câu sao
này các bạn phải làm xong hết cơ bản ở
Dương Mịch cho biết là có sao
à à
trò chơi boardgame mà được tôi rất thích
3 game
ờ ờ
Ừ chắc em đoán được bất ngờ gì rồi Không
không có một ai ở đây đoán được cái bất
ngờ của tôi luôn chỉ có duy nhất Cái đứa
ở không không không không nói gì vậy Nói
hết được à
ừ ừ
A giỏ hài có nên lưu season Công ạ Tại
sợ hết sơ sinh thì hết rồi hả Thì mình
nó nói mình dạy cái này thì ra nó không
phải phương pháp tối ưu khi mà thấy
lulua shisha nóng ạ nha để cho các bạn
biết qua về cách mạng 2 chiều mạnh như
chiều rồi thôi
A discourse nó người ngoài vô được không
Từ gas code của mình các bạn cứ tham gia
thôi mình thoải mái mà Thế mình mới để
công khai chứ không ạ nhưng mà nên là
vào đấy mà trao đổi học tập nhé Chắc
phải dạng như dysport của bên A như như
chú School hè bây giờ nó đang tập nhan
rồi
Lượm người vào đấy nhớ hơn 20.000 người
thôi nha thành sinh viên học phí tôi
khẳng định 1.000 người là căng thẳng
định thế luôn Mời ông vào rồi ông treo
luôn rồi đấy không Không nhắn tin thì
cho tôi khẳng định có rất nhiều ôm vào
đấy không nhắn tin gì cả khi tắt hết
toàn bộ thông báo ấy ừ ừ
anh hả
mà em ở đoạn văn trên mẹ thầy của bạn
này tra được à địa chỉ nhà tôi rồi cơ à
được đừng có qua đốt nhé
à à
ông thầy trị cách ném tài liệu lên ghế
thấp ấm rồi ông chỉ cần tạo file trên
đấy được mà ông upload file lên thôi họ
Ông nói cho ông dùng ít ông đẩy file lên
được mà ông đầy bất kỳ file đi lên đấy
cũng được mà cả cái ảnh file như gió
ừ ừ
à à
bộ mã hóa mật khẩu mã khóa mật khẩu
không phải là một cái gì đó
nâng cao đâu âm mưu Chỉ dùng một cái Hà
nó xong mà
à à
chị em bị ép không thấy gặp em trước khi
em đi cách ly được không
ông đuổi rồi đúng không
Ừ ông cách ly dị Xong rồi ông bảo vệ đồ
án thành công đi tôi sẽ gặp ông
30 people ship nó là giao diện rồi tôi
không quan tâm giao diện đâu
Có
khi nào một tí đau lưng
ờ
ờ kê con cái gì có thể khoe ở đây thôi
cho một tiếng 25 phút để để tôi xem thử
xem lại cái Ế
Ừ cái tôi lưu còn lưu
bộ đồ ăn tôm nhé
còn lưu này Ok tôi xin phép chia sẻ vậy
nhé đầu tiên thì tôi chia sẻ qua cái à
a
Point để cho ông xem PowerPoint trước
300 PowerPoint Chắc để cuối để hôm gần
bảo vệ đồ án này tôi sẽ chỉ cho mấy ông
Việt PowerPoint à
em có cái này để tôi xem thử
à à
Vì thế tôi xem thử ở ta bây thôi inbox
vào chưa
em có cái gì cũng còn nâng cao tôi rất
hào hứng vụ dẫn nâng cao đây nâng cao
chia sẻ hết toàn bộ nhưng cái có thể dạy
khi tải hình ơi tao bay thôi inbox rồi
có được không Cái này là khác rồi khác
rồi
chờ đợi tôi tí tôi sẽ à à
em xem lại code này
anh sạc pin tí code cô hồi đấy đặt vào
đấy thầy thôi không hướng dẫn cách cài
đặt tên file nhưng mà tôi đã biết cách
kiểu đặt tên nhiều cách giấy các tư thế
này còn một ông là bảo vệ đồ án cung Tôi
hứng lên viết hoa hướng lên công mà
hưởng sâu còn hứng lên cả giàu có dùng
cách này sợ thật
à à
Ê hồi nãy hãy Tôi không dạy mày cái mẹ
tôi có vẻ tôi Tôi cảm thấy là nên thế Nó
bắt chước à thêm con ếch TB là tên ông
khách say rồi khi được nghe tôi lại phải
lúc này đi
ở lại thì thôi inbox lại sau đó tôi cho
ông xem mấy ông xem qua à
Ô thế cái website nhé
Ừ
hỏi tôi dùng shopee
ừ ừ
à à
Đi Tìm website chính trong buồn cười
thật Huế cố tình trong thật buồn cười
ăn
mặn fast hồi lão phét rồi kìa Thì mảnh
như
chợ
đồ cổ hot
website chính
ở tại Bệnh để dò mấy ông lên à
Ê mấy ông Lê Na à đúng ơi thêm cả dạy
thuyết trình Ấn Tượng nữa cũng được
nghĩa chứa chì như kiểu tấu hay ấy về
trí là chính
là đúng rồi có bạn hỏi vụ câu thêm cơ sở
liệu vào để mà làm tính năng nâng cao
nhưng mà không kịp thời gian làm thì có
được không thì đưa cái là cái này nữa có
được không Có có làm chị ạ đương nhiên
các bạn thêm vào Các bạn làm không kịp
không hay trách các bạn cả những việc
với các bạn thêm tân trúc bảng hoặc là
thêm quá nhiều cột sau đó các bạn ý
là mỗi thứ một tí như tội nhấn mạnh đó
là các bạn phải xong hết cơ bản các bạn
mới nghĩ việc đấy cũng như à
anh cũng như là các bạn nói chung Vậy
tương đối phải xong cơ bản khi mà bảo vệ
đúng ạ Chứ không thể các bạn vì các bạn
nghĩ quá nhiều về nâng cao thành ra là
các bạn tốn quá nhiều vào việc
về việc cẩu tối ưu các thử Vân Vân Vân
sau đó thì về sau tính năng cơ bản còn
chưa xong thì các bạn chấp hành sẽ bị
khiển trách không ạ
Ừ vậy để xài có hỏi đấy
Ừ đợi tí a website của tôi đi tôi nói là
giao diện của tôi không đẹp chưa nghỉ để
mấy ông đừng nói vọng
Tải game Media rồi chữ cái chữ game đấy
bí đỏ
Ê hồi đấy đâu làm giao diện này nó diện
nền đen
vừa lấy cũng là một cách Thứ nhất là tôi
làm bàn laptop thì Gaming Gear nên tôi
nghĩa là mẹ tông nền đem đâu hợp lý rồi
thế mà cái cô cô nào cô hát ru cố tuyển
rộng bên nào về cứ ngồi trên mỗi xong
diện của tôi sao rủ các thầy không quan
tâm vì ta không quan tâm đến đối diện mà
nhờ thì ra có cái gì do Trọn Niềm đen
nữa bởi vì a lỗi của pp in ra chữ màu
đen thì nó sẽ bị ẩn đi Ở đây
hình nền đen ở sẽ không nhìn thấy lỗi
anh cái đấy à
ở bên đấy tôi ngồi mồm khá nhiều cái rồi
tôi chờ bị rảnh tôi ngồi mò nhiều ví dụ
mà tôi ngồi mò xem cái này có thêm
liveshows rồi mày không kiểu gì về sợ
mất trước sau này của tôi thể mỗi lần
tôi đến mùa này dòng béo với Bắt chước
cái cho lái sâu đấy Sao lợn sau đó thì à
Có ai đi định sản phẩm này đúng không ạ
Ở đây có cái tôi kết hợp cả tin tức các
tin tức có gì đâu mà qua bài Thôi thôi
chẳng biết làm tôi không làm cho nhiều
bài đâu đấy Thế thì em địa chỉ liên hệ
các thứ trống rất màu me ấy có thấy bắn
cả chúng có bán sản phẩm Vĩnh Điện được
thì cái đoạn này hiển thị lên của tôi ở
hồi ấy tôi tôi mở lên để mà hướng dẫn
sinh viên hay khủng với thủ rồi chứ
không phải lúc đầy mô Có hiển thị ra
dòng này đâu đấy
ở mấy cái hiện liên hệ chính sẽ bảo hành
được ra tôi đi thẳng HP pro nhé Chứ thực
ra nếu các bạn tối ưu hơn cả các bạn nên
cho có thể chỉnh sửa các bạn phải lưu
lại dp cho những cái này vào đăng nhập
đăng ký của Đội là Hồi đấy tôi đi vào
đấy tôi lên
Adam Store cho tôi thấy à Trên này có
thai menu 1 triệu nhá sau khi các bạn
kéo xuống đây này các bạn đi à
ở tay khi kéo xuống đây này thì thay
menu nói hiển thị ra kiểu khác khó nói
gì thì lên trên cùng như thế này theo
kiểu Pixie đấy sau đó tôi lên App Store
rồi Tôi ngồi mãi thôi vì sau thấy gợi ý
là dùng really có hư thứ khi mà Slow
xuống hiển thị menu kiểu khác đấy Đấy
sau sau đó thì tôi
tôi ngồi mò Nói chung rồi đấy tôi mò C
khá nhiều sau có làm cản mua đồ thị như
thế này trong ôm mèo nó
Ừ tôi làm vai đến được đúng mỗi cái đúng
mỗi cái này thôi mỗi cái này rồi là về
đến Còn tất cả những thằng khác không à
rất là đấy
hôi nghị Hình như hồi nãy vẫn còn làm
được à em quên chắc chân gì vậy Tôi thử
để chống xem nhé À 1
em tắt thử đi này
ừ ừ
khi đóng này o1 bằng một ít Limit 1 cho
chắc đi
đăng nhập này cái dùng request Ok tắt đi
qua đi là xong
đăng nhập này
khi đăng nhập thành công này ok
anh vào được rồi à
Ừ thôi đấy cũng không biết dùng elac cơ
bắt buộc phải có đầy đủ ngay đấy
số điện thoại điện thoại
cho số điện thoại này 097 805 ông ông
thích ông gọi số này đi
ở chỗ này tôi không biết của ai đâu
cho tất cả thông tin này được không tin
là mà Đó Tôi Đây chợ tranh khách hàng
này lịch sử mua hàng này thay đổi thông
tin cá nhân này đấy trông cũng chị dò và
không ạ chị soi thấy cả đầy đủ tính năng
thôi đấy
Vì
sao bò thì bên An mi này
sữa vinamill của mình là cái gì Đợi mình
tí
Cho xem Ben admin của Mỹ là
ở xã Trung này
à
à Hồi đấy con mình chơi cho nó không
không không có
em không có đường dẫn admin mà sẽ gọi là
admin log in a
ở nhà nóc in admin ở lock-in adminpro
Vinamilk nè rồi kìa nó in adminpro
phải để tự đặt tên buồn cười quá
Thấy không được chị
anh
nhớ cái này cũng cũng qua được
a
A1 = 1 unit 1 cho chắc
khi đăng nhập
em tắt cái quay đi à
ở đó mình đưa tự hack của chính mình
không ạ Ok ở đây ấn vào quản lý này quản
lý sản phẩm này
Ê hồi nãy tôi còn bị một cái đó là
ờ ờ
ở quầy áo tội bị nhà
giàu hà ngồi đấy bạn ông kia nhận làm
bây giờ hành với cùng đến 8 giờ tối chứ
không bảo vệ ông ấy gửi cho tôi cốt từ
trước đến nay của người cốt trong vòng 2
tháng ông gửi tôi toàn bộ cốt để tôi
ghét tôi đương nhiên là với cô ngày hôm
sau vẫn không làm được so với do hàng
may mà thầy cô cho qua thì cũng làm rất
nhiều tính năng khác rồi Cai vậy
ừ đấy ra mày ông lên làm đâu ghép Còn
đấy không Chuẩn đấy áo người cái bài
viết hồi này tôi cũng chưa nghĩ được
cách để mà chèn ảnh bài đăng vào nữa nên
tôi chơi cái trò đó chịu tách nói nhiều
cột Nếu nó sen đây không ạ tóm tắt này
Đoạn mở đầu đấy ảnh bài đăng này cho nội
dung muốn cười với chưa nhìn lại cốt
lông do mà thôi không quen nữa mày tự ai
nhiều đại khá như thế
chứ không phải con click đâu Có mỗi cốt
của ông đấy là mỗi cái bên giỏ hàng thôi
cũng không không chạy được đấy mà nó vẫn
gửi chồng cho mình ấy chứ chứ tôi không
tốt lên đấy mà tôi không Cốt thẳng lên
đầy luôn nó làm phần nào thì để phần nó
rồi đấy để hạn chế xung đồ rồi nhưng mà
cuối cùng đi ông ấy đặt tên biến đặt tên
file cứ loạn hết cả lên Vô Phi lỗi không
chạy được Nó không lại được nhưng nó vẫn
gửi cho mình như kiểu mày ngắm chưa Mày
là muốn đi Thế chịu
ừ ừ
à à
ờ ờ ờ Ok nói chung à Buồn Hôm nay chắc
thế thôi nhỉ 1 tiếng 30 phút rồi Nếu
không còn thắc mắc gì nữa
ừ ừ
để thêm sản phẩm
alo alo thêm sản phẩm
Ừ tao í bạn à Mình sản phẩm thêm cho bạn
bè
anh không chọn ảnh thôi áo mới cái ảnh
này hồi đấy đó tôi dùng cái cốt của thầy
cho mẫu trong nhóm chèo mãi không hiểu
thầy ông ấy thư viện này đâu ra chia sẻ
với bọn tôi từ năm này qua năm khác bấm
vào đây để chọn file ảnh này
cho anh xin mấy chưa
khi nghe giảng hình thấp lót này đó ốc
lá thành công bấm ở đây ăn continue để
vợ đó tiến hành nữa cả
Sao
không up hình sửa một đánh đâu nhé đại
khá như thế khi bấm vào lát ngay đúng
không Bấm ở đây để đưa đường dẫn và linh
mục nhập bấm ảo đó xin lại không hiểu
không hiểu Cố tận đây là cái gì Nó ngoài
ấy chưa ạ
à à
anh không mình trong khóa cơ bản này
mình dễ cân nhắc xem có nên chạy các bạn
sẽ lui cái thứ không như bạn chưa biết
thì
Ờ Ờ
thôi tạm thời thế đâu nhỉ
ừ ừ
U23 đại lỗi nói hết Thôi kệ đi rồi mới
thấy rồi bữa mày chắc à quá nhiều các
bạn thôi
Ừ nhưng mà đây tôi cho mấy ông xem đồ ăn
1 của tôi là chồng như nào đấy
ừ ừ
Xin chào bạn nhé Alo